[Música]
y
es muy difícil contestar preguntas
cuando estoy acostumbrada a realizarlas
hago periodismo y en ese caso las
preguntas las hago yo pero hace unos
años una y otra vez me hacen las mismas
cuestiones
para que corres
y otra vez vas a correr y para qué
corres tanto no te cansas
la verdad que no le puedo contestar esas
preguntas lo que sí le puedo contar es
en que me cambió la vida el correr
yo estaba en mi casa
con mis hijos hacia las cosas de la casa
tranquila fumaba pesaba más de 80 kilos
decía que fumaba 2 quería fumar 3 fumaba
más de 20 y en un momento dije basta
esto lo tengo que cambiar voy al
gimnasio deje de fumar
me puse a hacer un poco de gimnasia como
podía imaginarse años fumando mucho no
podía hacer
en un momento pero en el gimnasio un
cartel que dice carrera en rada tilly 5
y 10 km
y ahí en ese momento yo recordé unas
carreras que hacíamos en la ciudad de la
plata yo soy platense un supermercado
muy grande realizaba carreras de 4 y 8
kilómetros y nosotros con 15 años
imagínense íbamos por la bolsita con la
golosina en la gaseosa y a divertirnos
pero lo que me recordó ese cartel
fue esas mariposas en la panza que sentí
en ese momento donde hallamos 3000
personas
e hicieron un 5
2 1 y largamos esa emoción me vino en
ese momento y dije yo quiero hacer una
carrera fui y le dije a mi profesor
puedo correr 5 km me dijo claro hay que
prepararlo y ahí comenzamos la
preparación quedaba muy poco tiempo dijo
bueno empezar con la cinta corre empecé
a hacer escalador y en un momento me
dijo bueno ahora te toca salir a la
calle a correr me daba un poco de
vergüenza y salí me dijo tiene que
correr un kilómetro
con 300 metros camina el resto volví y
dije mira
y c300 y me dijo está bien no hay
problema esto vamos a mejorar no vos
podés largar y ahí estaba
en esa carrera por largar
y me preguntaba por qué vamos a correr y
claro si 1 vez del otro molde de otro
lado existe kansas
te metes en los ríos fríos tienes hambre
tienes sed
te vuelves a cansar tienes que subir
montañas tenés que bajar montañas
transpiras y la verdad que te preguntas
para qué corres
y yo les voy a decir que me cambio el
paradigma del por qué corres
porque tienes un cansancio de muerte
porque tenéis que subir montañas porque
tienes que cruzar ríos helados porque se
te congelan los párpados mientras estás
corriendo en una montaña nevada porque
tienes que subir montañas y volverlas a
subir
y allí estábamos muchísimas personas
congregadas en esa carrera de rada tilly
y empezó el 321 y largamos otras veces
las cosquillas en la panza y largamos
los 5 km logré cruzar la meta y mi
marido me dijo quédate con la primera la
primera corro 10 kilómetros yo corrí 5
no importa eso no me lo quita nadie
yo sigue con la primera
y dije esto es lo que tengo que hacer
esto es lo que me hace feliz
me metí en esos clubs de running todos
larga van a correr el calor yo intentaba
respirar
cuando ellos volvían yo iba y así
viceversa hasta que bueno pasaron los
meses obviamente la constancia y la
perseverancia hacen que puedas lograr lo
que vos aún no crees
y empecé a correr empecé a hacer un
kilómetro 23 56 me anoté en carreras de
porque no 21 kilómetros y larga y
veintiún kilómetros y ese día dije
llegué a lo máximo
esta fue la foto de mi primera carrera
aquella que largué que llegue con la
primera la de 5 km ustedes quédense con
que llegue primera
y larga 21 kilómetros y
dije esto tiene que ser más porque
porque durante esos 21 kilómetros yo me
sentí muy bien y quería más entonces me
puse en manos de un experto en montaña y
dije voy a correr 42 kilómetros de
montaña por supuesto que todo esto trajo
el cambio de alimentación
empezó a tomar más líquido porque los
corredores no comemos un plato de fideos
hacemos carga de carbohidratos
no comemos un asado con mismas proteínas
para alimentar el músculo
empiezas a conocerte el cuerpo de pronto
decís voy a estirar el isquiotibial
o estás entrenando y sexting o cargado
el tensor de la fascia lata nunca en mi
vida pensé que teníamos un músculo que
se llame tensor de la patria la talla si
estamos conociéndonos empezás a comer
distinto
en mi caso dejé las harinas empecé a
entrenar y mucho es algo que vos tenés
que hacer en el día y en eso digo en que
me cambió la vida correcta en que antes
yo miraba tele veía si me quedaban unos
cigarrillos me tenía que ir a comprar
sistema quedaban dos o tres y ahora mi
vida se transformaba en tengo que ir a
entrenar tengo que ir a correr tengo que
ir a subir cuestas empezaste a cambiar
la vestimenta porque ahora no te compran
las zapatillas
por cómo lucen el color las compras y
sos perdonad ahora sí quizás para afuera
su peinado ahora si haces la pisada para
adentro neutral si venís bien empezás a
comprarte zapatillas de cerro o de calle
tenés de entrenamiento de carreras
empezamos a tener remeras y remeras y
remeras de carrera en todo tu ropero que
después empezás a descartar porque es
una cosa que ya no se puede creer
empezás a coleccionar medallas
querés correr por la medalla y eso lo
que más te gusta
y nos pusimos a entrenar para 42 km mi
profesor dijo quieren correr 42
kilómetros de montaña suban esa cuesta 6
veces
la cuesta bastante empinada por supuesto
llegamos a 3 y estábamos con la lengua
acá eso que estábamos entre la dijo
bueno si ustedes quieren hacer esto
tienen que hacerlo conscientemente
empezamos a entrenar siete días a la
semana uno descansa vamos que también
ese entrenamiento y así largamos los 42
kilómetros y cuando cruce la meta nos
dijo nuestro entrenador tienen que hacer
5 sentadillas cosas que hicimos y ahí
dije no yo no me quedo con esto me sentí
más más bien tipo los 21 quiero ser
ultramaratonista ultramaratón
son más de 42 km
y preguntaba a la gente que corría hace
mucho que sentís y que piensas mientras
corres
y son unas 10 12 horas que estás
corriendo y claro que piensas
y cuando vas corriendo lo que pensás es
tengo que comer tengo que tomar tengo
que ponerme el gel gel es un aparatito
chiquito así que te tomas que tiene
carbohidratos que tiene proteínas que
soluciona la vida si no tienes que
comerte entonces dos o tres sandwiches
como para poder seguir corriendo 12
horas y así la raya ni primer ultra
mi primer otro maratón los largos que
van muy preparadas es el examen como me
tomé de largo otra vez esas cosquillas
en la panza saltando feliz emocionada y
en el kilómetro 25
me tropiezo
quedé tirada en el piso y dije se
terminó todo
se terminó mi carrera se terminó lo que
viene hacer es terminar lloraba vinieron
a ayudarme todos mis compañeros de
carrera gente que no te conoce te ayuda
a levantarte poder no lloro llamaron a
auxilios para que vengan a ayudarme y en
un momento dije no
si yo me dedico al ultramaratón el
ultramaratón es la vida si en la vida a
vos te caes y te quedas ahí caída
la verdad que no está buena intenté
levantarme me levanté pisé y vi que no
me había fracturado nada dije wow
continuaremos continue logre cruzar la
meta de 54 kilómetros por supuesto que
después tenía un melón en el tobillo me
había cortado el tendón extra galliano
insisto sigo sin conocer del todo todos
los músculos y yo le decía kinesiólogo
pero no puede ser me dice si no está al
tendón te lo cortaste así todo a los 20
días empezó a tratar de nuevo porque eso
es lo que yo quería me cambio de vida es
estar corriendo es estar disfrutando
ustedes me dicen disfrutar de 15 horas
corriendo sí porque vos subís montañas
ves el cerro tronador en la palma de tu
mano
bajas y berríos que nunca podrías ver si
no llegas allí con tus propias piernas
te emocionas yo realmente como grande
emociono conseguidos y no sólo la
largada sino cuando subo una montaña y
veo cosas que no lo puedo creer bescós
cascadas que la verdad no las conocería
si no fueras hasta allí corriendo cruzar
ríos y te congelas y te cabeza en ríos
también te caes en el barro claro te
enteras en la nieve hasta acá también y
eso es disfrute aquello que yo
disfrutaba que era fumar lo cambié por
subir montañas
y así todo bueno 6 un deporte familiar
mi marido también corre mis hijos
también un poco me siguieron y así la
vida te va cambiando ya hizo otra ya es
otra cosa mientras corres se te abre la
cabeza
yo estuve diez años aquí viviendo sedes
de la plata estoy hace 18 más 14 años y
no pude nunca trabajar de periodista y
al correr a conocer gente nueva ya
conocer gente que tiene energía te dicen
que no sé es un programa de radio ya que
vos trabajabas de periodista no o si
como y así comencé también a tener una
carrera profesional porque comencé con
un programa de radio efecto running
conocí gente maravilloso unos unos
relatos hermosos
qué es lo que mejor me queda de toda
esta experiencia conocer gente nueva
empezás a viajar por el país a trabajar
pasa trabajo el mío ir a correr y contar
de qué se tratan las carreras
y empezar también a tener una carrera
profesional que decir
y si nos vamos a europa a correr una
carrera
ahí estábamos fuimos a las islas
canarias con mis compañeros lo sabe él
es mi marido y allí estábamos otra vez a
las 3 de la mañana
al lado de un faro de fuencaliente
faltaban tres horas para largar y
estábamos todos en una piedra se veía el
contenido se concebía en ese momento yo
dije
estoy acá entre toda esta gente yo que
empecé con justamente la misma cantidad
de kilos con la distancia que iba a
correr 76 la primera carrera
y estoy acá con toda esta gente yo no
emoción medio muy grande porque no podía
creer que aquí estaba yo y empezó una
largada en cinco idiomas
y cuando fue en español largamos
y allí estábamos subiendo otra vez la
montaña 5000 metros son 50 cuadras para
arriba para poder llegar al punto límite
y después ya empezar a bajar 25 km las
primeras tres horas fueron tremendas
porque granizo hubo vientos como nunca
hay en las canarias viento commodores yo
dije bueno ya estoy acostumbrada de
fiesta a las canarias para que es el
mismo viento pero bueno ahí estábamos
con lluvia
y en eso dije yo acá abandono no puedo
más había cometido un error de comer la
verdad al no comer harinas leeré con los
carbohidratos
y en ese momento se me apareció la cara
de mis dos hijos
me estaban esperando
y dije de hecho tengo que seguir yo
estoy acá es el ultramaratón es la vida
cómo voy a abandonar
y me hubiese perdido de esto
sigue 15 horas después mi hijo me estaba
esperando
me hizo el aguante durante un minuto
diciéndome ya llega este mamá o sea este
mamá
y ahí estaba logre cruzar la meta y
logré superarme a mí misma con esto yo
no quiero que cambien de ropa se vayan a
correr sean ultramaratonistas ni nada
por el estilo
yo lo que les digo es que busquen su
pasión
si ven un violín y les emociona tocar
violín si ver una pintura
y les dan ganas de pintar y bueno pinten
escriban rompan mil hojas si quieren
pero escriban hagan lo que sea mientras
sea su pasión porque a partir de una
pasión que vos tenés adentro
se abre un mundo maravilloso
busquen su pasión en donde sea en una
piedra entendieras lo que sea
o estén atentos
porque quizás la pasión
los puede estar esperando como me
esperaba a mirar que el cartel muchas
gracias
[Música]
tú